hey Kona 360 live this is John Carew
news from Warner Brothers Studio to our
Hollywood
I'm currently inside of the picture car
vault or as I like to call it the
Batcave I'm going to show you around
some of my absolute favorite things
follow me over to this Batmobile here
now what you see is the Batmobile from
Batman Forever
that's where Val Kilmer played Bruce
Wayne and Batman crazy fact the radio in
here is stuck forever unseals kiss from
a rose it's the only thing to plays
inside of the car we also have the bikes
from Batman and Robin we have Robins red
bird we have batgirls bat blade we also
have the original the number one hero
car from Batman 1989 Michael Keaton's
car now that's of course the one that
Tim Burton originally directed and from
the Knowland trilogy the bat statue it's
probably kind of hard to see the entire
thing but he's got no pants on who would
make a statue like that clearly some of
the absolute most imposing things in
this exhibit look behind you the
tumblers from the Dark Knight trilogy
now this is where Christopher Nolan took
over directing and you can really see
the realistic aspect of Batman these are
the real deal they really run and they
are the originals they have Chevy 350
small block v8 engines in there so Bruce
Wayne while you know he hasn't really
philanthropic guy apparently the
environment in terms of gas mileage not
on his list of priorities and that's
fine now you see the camouflage tumbler
really make its its appearance in the
Dark Knight Rises
but the black tumbler really carries its
way through the Batman Begins and the
Dark Knight but behind me we're gonna
take a closer look at the Joker car here
we are inside of the Joker's car what an
experience look at this thing we got
velour all over the roof it's on the
panels
it's like blinged out to the max there's
Gold everywhere gold shifter I don't
know if you can see down there but there
are custom Joker mats there's like
snakeskin everywhere this thing has to
be a monster to actually clean but look
at this diamond-encrusted steering wheel
surprisingly good for grip I can see why
he has that it's amazing and you know
reinforced roof because at some point
it's bound to happen
somebody dressed up as a bat is gonna
land right on the roof punch a hole
through the thing rip the Joker out
tight quarters - I can see he gets
really nuzzled up - Harley Quinn it
makes it really easy for a romantic date
night
you know man I got to get me one of
these that's gonna do it for me again
everybody thank you for checking out
some of my favorite things but we
encourage you to come see for yourself
so join us book your tickets at WB
studio tor.com what else can I say about
this exhibit besides the fact that it's
the bane of my existence don't just
bring your nuclear family because this
place is the bomb I am so sorry